plus prix des fromages québécois est il
plus élevé que les fromages français
la réponse est oui dans plusieurs cas et
on vous explique pourquoi ce soir avec
le professeur daniel mercier gouin
spécialiste des questions agricoles
spécialiste de l'agro économie de
l'université laval bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur fillion vous nous parler de
cela ce soir parce que l'une de vos
étudiante a fait son mémoire de maîtrise
en agroéconomie sur cette question des
fromages tout à fait on avait pas
jusqu'à maintenant de travail qui avait
été fait sur le processus de formation
du prix des fromages pour comprendre
qu'est ce qui se passe du producteur
jusqu'au consommateur et donc c'est
sandrine bureau votre étudiante qui a
réalisé cela on va tout de suite montré
le premier graphique que vous avez
préparé pour nous expliquer exactement
ce que ça veut dire le prix d'un fromage
artisanal québécois à l'épicerie puis à
la fromagerie
oui tout à fait alors c'est une enquête
qui étaient faits auprès de neuf fromage
hysice fromages ont été enquêtés et ici
on présente un peu le résultat moyen
pour ses fromages la sanction par dudu
pied de la colonne prix au consommateur
à l'épicerie mais on a en bas le prix du
lait qui lit on dans un kilo de fromage
donc la valeur du lait dans ce kilo de
fromage et de 8 et 32
ensuite le transformateur pour son coût
de production son profit pour
transformer le fromage
il se prend une marge de 19 dollars et
20 une marche ça veut pas dire un profit
ainsi la différence entre son prix
d'achat et le prix de vente
ensuite il remet ça à un distributeur
qui vient chercher des fromages à l'
usine de transformation et qui lui même
va se prendre une marche pour l'amener
chez les détaillants ou à l'entrepôt des
détaillants et lui sa marge doit être de
5 $ et 64 et finalement le détaillant se
prend une marge de 24 dollars
quarante deux pour cent quarante deux
pour sa dû privant d'un donc de 57 17
qui est la marge du détaillant mais là
on est vraiment dans des fromages de
spécialité des fromages fins on parle
pas ici de cheddar on parle de fromage
que vont faire des petites fromageries
artisanales ou des produits par
transformateur donc des fromages haut de
gamme et ce qu'on constate finalement
c'est qu'une bonne part en fait plus
moitié du prix final d'un fromage est
accaparée par les marges de la
distribution et des détaillants et donc
quand on va à la fromagerie c'est moins
cher à pourvoir la fromagerie c'est
moins cher donc on a le même prix du
lait le même art transformateurs mais
pour avoir sa boutique à l'usiné ou chez
le producteur quand un producteur
transformateur
évidemment pour le service qui donne lui
aussi se prénommant gilles henriot des
coûts et donc en moyenne en général
c'est moins cher quand on va l'acheter
directement à la fromage
donc ça c'est le fromage artisanal au
québec tu te fais la comparaison des
prix le camembert le camembert et
français oui il est vendu bien sûr en
france
il est vendu au québec et il ya un titre
camembert québécois également qu'il
serait intéressant il ya des écarts de
prix assez spectaculaire 10,4 de plus
spectaculaire alors là pour le camembert
notre source de données c'est l'office
des prix et des marges en france
cet office des prix des marges ont été
mis en place il ya quelques années pour
le gouvernement français
justement pour démystifier cette
question de la formation des prix et
pour éviter que les acteurs d'une
filière se battent sur des fausses
perceptions de qui capte la marge est
donc ils font pour toutes sortes de
produits pour les viandes prennent
toutes sortes de produits et pour le
camembert et plus spécifiquement pour le
camembert président et donc on peut
avoir l'information alors en france le
prix du lait qui va dans ce fromage les
2 3 et 60 oui pour un kilo de fromage la
marche du transformateur et 3 et 45 et
la marge des distributeurs détaillants
de 2 et 54 et finalement la taxe à la
valeur ajoutée qui est perçu en france
le même camembert arrivent au québec les
prix augmentent alors premièrement varga
b qui intervient donc on a le même prix
du lait la même marge des
transformateurs et un coup pour amener
ce fromage
ici le coup de l'exportation le
transport la douane et cetera ensuite
l'importateur qui détient le droit
d'importer des fromages parce que c'est
des contingents tarifaires ou des quotas
d'importation
il ya comme une rampe d'importation donc
c'est son profit sur l'importation et
ensuite distributeurs et détaillants qui
prennent 17 et 47 et là qui prennent la
moitié c'est même plus que la moitié
plus que la moitié du prix par contre il
faut faire attention parce que j même si
je prends le même produit un camembert
par exemple président en france et au
québec
c'est quand même pas le même produit et
je m'explique
ici un camembert français c'est un
produit haut de gamme - et donc sur des
produits haut de gamme mais les marges
sont généralement plus élevés et en
france le camembert président s'est pas
un produit haut de gamme c'est un
produit qui est dans le croquant dans le
comptoir à côté d'eux les mentale
industriel absolument que la logique de
marge est pas tout à fait la même
on termine donc avec le titre camembert
québécois alors là on a fait des
hypothèses et a dit qu'on parle d'un
prix du lait parce qu'on sait le prix
qui est payé pour est ici au québec pour
acheter du lait pour faire du fromage et
on part du prix au détail parce que les
grands transformateurs au québec ce type
camembert industriels québécois nous ont
pas donné accès à leurs données
ça se comprend un peu ils sont deux ou
trois s'ils donnent accès aux données il
a des concurrents mais on le déduit à
partir du prix observée à l'épicerie la
marche qui ce brun est donc ce que ça
nous donne comme résultat le prix du
lait ccl 30 de la part du transformateur
10 et 85 et finalement près de 21 à 20 $
pour le distributeur et le détaillant
donc ça c'est une approximation ça nous
donne une idée mais ce qu'on constate
c'est qu'encore une fois la distribution
c'est la moitié du coût aux
consommateurs dans ces familles dable
c'est très clair on devrait avoir le
prix comme ça au détail pour tous les
produits n'est ce pas ça serait bien si
on avait nos fils démarche merci
beaucoup pour cette démonstration très
clair ça m'a fait plaisir